have you watched archer the tv show uh
little bits of the uh yeah there's a
really weird thing that just completely
caught me off guard so um they did an
episode about like
a very um famous welsh event that
happened and it was very weird that
archer an american comedy tv show did
this yeah so there's a thing called uh
truetin in wales right and uh this is a
small town uh that no longer exists okay
because uh liverpool which is a
city in england uh wanted a reservoir
so their solution to getting a reservoir
was to just flood this town
so they could get water holy [ __ ] i
should you not so they had to evacuate
they literally just made people just
move wow okay and whilst people weren't
allowed to vote and whether this was
yeah so they had no say they had no say
right so they just flooded this town
called trueden and turned it into a
reservoir turned out they didn't even
need it in the end
and then they they killed like four
people as well because some people
refused to leave holy [ __ ] so they they
flooded it
you can go there it's depressing as [ __ ]
because they're just like buildings
underneath this reservoir
and there's a bunch around the area
there's a ton of like remember remember
and it's just it's seen as one of the
most like
injustices that were done to work yeah
that's pretty funny it's very shitty
fairly recent as well how recent we're
talking
i think 60s can you google it it's like
60s 80s around that time i think just
true adding tr what why
that's just the plot to higarash
they're like gonna build a dam and then
they'll like protest and like stop the
people
so english people could drink water and
then they didn't even use it
it's like what the [ __ ] and then also
archer just did an episode about it
they did a whole thing of like they were
like i'm on twitter yeah
965. yeah
they have like a whole joke about it
because like they were like it's one of
the most enjoy and they were all like
like nah don't worry about it yeah
justice
wow that's something everyone needs to
care about that is something yeah you're
all educated on true adam i mean that's
the very basic story there's a lot more
yeah that's other people can tell that i
feel like when you're from a small
nation that just doesn't get a lot of
attention from the world media in
general because that's that's me
whenever like
thailand gets mentioned anywhere right
like like i i i'm just happy if like
thailand is just brought up in any kind
of capacity i'm just everyone everyone
knows my country now that's uh i love it
they get like insanely excited and like
anything happens like they're just
insane it's great i i remember when i
was passionate about anything yeah right
i remember when i went to a con in
singapore uh the company oh they're like
shouting at you in public yeah no no no
yeah that one but like i remember i did
a i did a panel there and i literally
all i literally said was hello singapore
and i've never heard a crowd of people
like crying and screaming
it was as if like [ __ ] elvis presley
came on stage and like said their
country's name it was like he said the
country name ladies and gentlemen
honestly the singapore convention was
like crazy that was insanely [ __ ] the
most i wasn't i wasn't invited i wasn't
invited i mean i wasn't invited i was
just there for the ride yeah because
i was we weren't tied at this point when
i wasn't
you know we we knew each other
yeah yeah i was already in thailand he
was literally just next yeah
he's like i'm gonna pop down to
singapore yeah no the guy literally
texted me and was like oh you're in
singapore finna pop down for a quick
second
yeah it's it's so weird sometimes where
what we are as southeast asians are
proud of sometimes because like it's
like i swear to god every time i meet a
fellow southeast asian from a different
country we get competitive over like the
weirdest things right because the first
thing we compare is um how [ __ ] it is to
drive on our roads yeah
like i don't know why we do that is it
like it's like yo you're still alive
nice
why is just like oh there's one time in
bangkok i was in traffic for one hour oh
when i oh you think one hour is bad when
i was in jakarta it was a three-hour
traffic jam once and i'm just like
thinking about this i'm just like why
are we comparing why would this is like
the weirdest dick size comparison i can
think of oh you survived two car crashes
yeah i survived four
that's not something to be proud of
because i was just like i caused all of
them
because after living in two years sydney
just went around to other people being
like you know thailand has like thailand
is like second on like the most
dangerous place to drive in the world
and i live there and i'm just like
sydney why are you why are you posting
about like why i can't even drive there
why are we boasting about that
she's saying all this like in the
passenger seat
it's like it's like how i went here go
to my university town was like number
one for like heroin usage in the uk
we were like yeah number one yeah
number one
yeah
heroin number one
heroin number one wales let's go
like where i grew up was like number one
for like teen pregnancy in the uk as
well yeah and then there was just like a
fact they were like good be proud of it
we're finally number one in something
so all of your parents here are still
teenagers congratulations that's kind of
what it's like in a small town
i just i just realized that's exactly
where the same way as where sydney comes
from
the first thing she boasts about uh from
like wisconsin it's just like two things
we're like we're like cheese we're like
number one in cheese beers and serial
killers
i don't think that's a good thing sydney
being number one in cheese in the us is
not a that's like saying you know you're
you're number one landlocked country in
like some [ __ ] i don't know town i
don't know [ __ ] [ __ ] terrible
comparison but i know what you mean it's
like it's it's not something to be like
oh wow amazing i mean what is amazing is
the fact that [ __ ] that state is the
most serial killers like that's that's
pretty impressive honestly